i don't know if it's possible to play
queen c5 that's also an option by the
way do you think the white knight just
goes back and tries to maybe after that
uh what about queen c no queen state is
not good okay he's actually played queen
c5 so the most ambitious move but well
he goes for activity and don't forget
that after queen c5 white can also get
in trouble for the first time yeah
vikings suddenly for the first time it
can also be after 93 96
and black is extremely stable
and for example after h6
you just want
but g6 is hd6h7 h7 that is a huge
problem for black so after
six
maybe not so easy suddenly maybe you
have to go back with the queen to f8
but then suddenly it feels like whites
made some gains
g4 maybe
look at that knight e3 is on the board
magnus spent down under three minutes
still hard to predict in knight e3 it
was extremely difficult to play what a
battle yeah between c3 h6
so magnus just offered a pawn sacrificed
it
it does look dangerous
it does look very dangerous for blacks
i'm not sure that black can take on c3
and the players have to be so sharp in
such a situation you might be going back
26 and you're going finish six actually
that's uh one of the options but i'm not
sure then it was a good decision to go
queen c5 or knight e6
knight e6 what we've looked at and after
h6 to go back with f8
this looks uh
knight g4 it still looks very
but after knight g4 you can go g6 i
think
queen d6
okay very stressful moments for the
players
magnus went under two minutes by now
but he feels that he's pressing
yeah maybe black should be already going
to this direction of uh but what about
playing actively queen d1 okay and
h6
h6 g6
yeah
knight f6 check
yeah and queen
right yeah so there are some dangers for
that it's getting very very difficult
queen g4 white makes space for his
knight on f5
it's getting more and more stressful for
black yeah that's the dream square right
f5 in an attack
yeah and he's uh but if he could go for
a queen trade now somehow well probably
he should be
playing queen e6 knight f5 what about
playing g6
okay
and it's not something he wants to do
but maybe he has to do
no but that's
maybe dropping a point but
okay the king moves
but where yeah maybe
g7
yeah g7 takes and knight takes so it
seems like just in time
g6 on the board okay g6 actually it's
not a bad decision i guess because
knight f5 was definitely something you
don't want to see tonight on f5 giving
checks on e7
with two minutes left yeah on the top of
that
okay so bishop h6 was magnus's reply
now is he
in some situation maybe going to take
that knight on f8 just to go for a good
night bishop scenario he may very easily
and we'll see another 50 moves of
grinding and trying to get that knight
to its ideal outposts
yeah because if black can black even
move that night it feels very shaky
the knight d7 for example feels like it
might run into some tactical well knight
d7 knight
f5 queen e6 let's say
but maybe black is just hanging on yeah
i mean i would want to keep that night
alive ideally but
right now we see on the clocks 123 for
magnus and 135
four three
two
oh how much i don't want to be in
black's place yeah it's become a bullet
game and that's one area that magnus
except d7 is on the board okay so 97 is
predicted keeping the knight on the
board but
this is one area where magnus he has so
much experience reports
online at least doesn't say now the
question is
let's say what is it if it takes and
queen takes
it seems like black can save it probably
so each stage g6 will not happen here i
think black knight comes to c5 very
quickly suddenly as well yeah so black
is looking for some contour chances of
course it's extremely stressful
magnus is under a minute
what is going to be happening still in
this game i have a feeling he'll play a
move like bishop g5 or okay he's gone
knight c4 attacking the black witch's
sides
okay actually the black queen is
overworked suddenly oh she has to defend
d7 but maybe it is something very bad
happening night
knight f6 only move or what is knight f6
that was knight f6
does this it's not dropper pawn it looks
like but maybe it's uh
yeah i thought maybe black could have
played queen e6 exchanging the queens
and gone from knight c5 gone for white's
pawns but
okay now we white gives a check the
black queen drops back and the pawn
bones are falling apart okay white's
simply going to take on jesus jesus okay
he's played bishop g5 first
that's very accurate and now bishop g5
yeah
that's a pin he's going to take on f6
next move and take on a5 and that a pawn
is
annoying bishop g5 in this position look
rapport he's got his head in his hands
he was shaking his head there as well
yeah it was the clock he just didn't
have any time to work things out
and suddenly it's all by force maybe he
thought that white would take on g6
there he had time for knight takes e4
but
well he's going to go
g takes h5 knight e5 king g7
[Music]
knight c6 bishop c7
does
does white not just go for the a pawn
instead okay he has taken on h5 can not
white try and rush uh with bishop f6 and
knight a5 right but unless the black
king comes across in time well takes six
knight a5 okay black has to go king of
f8 i think otherwise just knight takes
c6 and a5 king f8
k8
well i mean it's a bad wind right yeah
the knight is too strong on d5
so it looks like magnus he is
in charge now the clock still factor but
well he went under a minute but that
will not change i think
the
final result and he goes to simplify the
position the way
that is the most painful for black
taking on f6 taking on a5 and what a
comeback
by magnus
making
really so
interesting what will be the outcome of
the tournament still yeah it's three
games in a row now he's really squeezed
out these dry positions and
um yeah right now knight takes a five
just knight c6 and running the airport
is
a decisive threat it will be i think
impossible for
okay rap order not much of a
counter chance that he can
he can think of even though he's a very
creative player very original
very resourceful
but this is not the position anymore
where he can
save it
no this one should be a matter of
technique if white can somehow
force the h pawn force black h pawn to
move forward and get the white king into
the game later regroups his knight to d5
sensible start the black king will
probably just shift over to d7
the black bishop will maybe sit back on
d8 okay there we go you should d8
immediately he doesn't like to have his
divide born on c6
okay so
knight d5 or
knight d3
okay a very off anderson type of
knight d3 you just love that square for
his night in every position
well it's a very nasty way of playing
right after f6 probably
he maybe just wants to go king h3 i
don't know
yeah
and black's bishop if it sits on c7 the
same white king
starts making its journey forward
yeah
magnus he's so accurate and
it's going to be hard to fight back now
for report
okay he does play f6 but now those pawns
are in dark squares why it's king
at this point it's choosing between bad
and worse yeah
what's the least bad right now
it's hard to say kd7 okay
only some kind of study-like solution
can save at some point true rapport
of course now king
if it would be king h4 then f5 some
simplification some practical chances
but f3 is played yeah why risk it why
not defend all your pawns put them on
light squares before marching in with
the white king
and the problem is for black now he's
forcing
c4
and then he's
even if white would've played king h4 to
be honest it's
yeah but right to play king c4 king h4
right when you can play c4 and after
that but you go king h4 and also the h5
phone will be even in a dream scenario
that's
yeah there's no bishop one check
fortunately for rapport
because the white knight defends that
square and yeah
impossible to stop the white king
entering
well magnus is so good in
collapsing points when
yeah that's the sign of a champion right
the key games absolutely give all your
energy absolutely
so we are having a position which there
is not much of a chance for black
but it's so painful to resign this game
of course
i mean it's
you can always resign
and uh okay
of course it's extremely painful because
he was hanging on for such a long time
and of course in such a cases you feel
it so much
that it was a draw yeah how could i lose
this
at the same time you play against magmas
who had so
such a patience
especially in the way it happened it was
just a one with blunder in a way as well
yeah but there it was uh i mean this is
some pressure this is the end of it
right it doesn't come from one moment to
another then you're pressed press press
press press eventually you let it go for
a second then
and okay white's king is now entering
there's no way to shoulder it off with
the black king
and yeah we'll see resignation any
moment do you think rapport will be able
to pick himself up from this defeat
well he should be able to because after
all even this game he played pretty well
it was just he slipped away
on the way where it was possible to make
those mistakes right
at some point it was all about intuition
and
nerves also yeah but magnus is is so
great in that so i don't think uh he
should be ashamed of the fact that he's
losing against magnus carlsen with the
black pieces in this way
and uh do you think you'll regret giving
magnus his like a magnus type of
position or do you think he'll regret
not playing a more active opening maybe
uh i think
first of all it's very difficult to make
the solution
that that will work against magnus it's
always the case i think that you make a
solution what should i do this or that
and depending on how the game
goes you will regret it or not yeah but
i mean magnus
played very well this game i think
he really felt all the details
and we just see him putting the
finishing touches in white's pawn
marching forward he resigned eventually
very painful loss
but okay this is sport right yeah so
this is how
everybody is excited
that the rapport is still keeping his
lead but only very very very tiny half a
point